poignée de main entre Catherine Colonna
et son homologue Nitro couliba le
message est clair la France est à vos
côtés elle est votre ami la ministre
française des Affaires étrangères qui
est acquiev donc ce mercredi c'est la
troisième visite dans la capitale
ukrainienne depuis le début de
l'invasion russe la France veut
souligner son appui politique militaire
humanitaire aux Ukrainiens elle va
rencontrer par ailleurs Catherine
Colonna le président zellenski et elle
l'a rencontré le procureur général
qui enquête sur de possibles crimes de
guerre commis à isum et puis Bruno Darou
la ministre a également annoncé un
septième train de sanction contre la
Russie qui s'apprête donc annexer les
territoires occupés alors c'est un
septième ou un huitième on sait plus
trop mais enfin bon de toute façon
l'information effectivement qui nous
était parvenu de Bruxelles mais qui est
donc confirmé par Catherine Colonna et
aussi par son homologue ukrainien c'est
qu'il peut y avoir donc des sanctions
qui vont être prises contre les
personnes qui ont organisé les pseudos
référendums que l'on voit actuellement
dans les territoires
Ukrainiens conquis par la Russie ou dans
les soi-disant républiques indépendantes
de louansk et denietzk le ministre
ukrainien d'ailleurs est resté sur une
ligne très ferme en faisant comprendre
que c'était pas le moment des
négociations et que la Russie ne
cherchait pas la paix et que sur ces
référendum il fallait en fait que les
pays européens et occidentaux plus
largement et réagissent avec fermeté
parce que sinon ce serait un mauvais
signal envoyé à Vladimir Poutine qui
considérait qu'en fait il peut faire un
peu ce qu'il veut donc ces sanctions ont
été également confirmés par la ministre
française des Affaires étrangères qui
par ailleurs vous l'avez dit à décliner
un peu le les différents champs d'action
de la France pour aider l'Ukraine et
vous avez raison le message principal
c'est que et elle l'a répété quand même
plusieurs fois
la France et l'ami de l'Ukraine la
France soutient l'Ukraine non seulement
maintenant mais aussi après la guerre le
ministre ukrainien qui a affirmé que la
Russie ne voulait pas de négociation ça
c'est une pique on disait antenne à
Emmanuel Macron qui lui poursuit le
dialogue avec en tout cas ce qu'il a dit
c'est que c'était pas le moment pour des
négociations et en tout cas pas le
moment pour des médiations puisque selon
Monsieur coulibat la Russie ne veut pas
la paix là aussi ne veut pas de
négociation donc ça sert pas à grand
chose dans l'immédiat si on comprend
bien ce qu'il dit de chercher à garder
un canal de communication avec la Russie
donc oui là on pouvait voir peut-être de
manière implicite un petit tacle à la
position française mais enfin sinon
globalement quand même de part et
d'autre le ton a été extrêmement
chaleureuse le ministre d'ailleurs a
remercié la France pour la livraison
d'armes et on a donc appris là qu'il y
aurait de nouvelles fournitures si on a
bien compris de canon César pour aider
l'armée ukrainienne et au total on a eu
quand même le chiffre puisque vous savez
que la France avait été critiquée la
semaine dernière par l'ancien secrétaire
général de l'OTAN Rasmussen sur sa
faible implication on a eu le chiffre
quand même d'un d'une implication
financière globale de la France à 2
milliards de dollars merci beaucoup
Bruno